[Music]
we're excited to share a first look at a
project we're developing at ubisoft san
francisco
this is our take on a multiplayer first
person shooter
we need to get you in early and find out
what you think our goal is to make a
best-in-class shooter for you
the players to compete and have fun with
your friends
it's fast paced fire fights meets punk
rock mosh pit
we're proud to introduce our new game
tom clancy's
ex-defiant your feedback is essential to
help us make this game great
later in this video we'll tell you how
to get involved but first
we'll get into the action
this is a free-to-play high-octane
shooter
combining realistic gun play with
personalized classes
those classes are represented in our
game as factions
each bringing unique gameplay and team
dynamics
every faction comes equipped with traits
abilities
and an ultra to complement your
playstyle and the faction's role
used skillfully each faction is capable
of swinging the momentum of a match
our factions are at the heart of the
game they're inspired by maverick groups
from across tom clancy's games and
beyond
from this inspiration we created new
characters
and gameplay unique to our shooter
and will continue to add to this diverse
cast as the game evolves
now while factions help you define your
role we know
to be a great shooter the gun play has
to be our top priority
we have an ever growing arsenal of
authentic weapons
and attachments we put a lot of care
into
how our weapons look and feel we've
crafted
every weapon attachment for precise
satisfying gun play
players can mix and match any faction
and weapon loadout
you can swap at respawn to adapt to a
changing battlefield
personalize your faction and loadout to
be what you need
when you need it and i can't stress this
hard enough
we are a shooter first
and your abilities and ultras create
unique opportunities
to set up nail-biting shootouts and
unforgettable clutch plays
personalizing classes guns and gear in a
fast-paced fight is a whole new
experience
in tom plancy gaming
we are super stoked by what we've
accomplished so far
and i couldn't be more proud of our
incredible team
we want to personally thank everyone
that's worked so hard during the
pandemic to keep the momentum going on
this game
we understand that it's been even harder
for some of you we hope that we can
build a community that's a place where
people can connect and have fun
and we're committed to creating a
welcoming game based on fair play and
transparency whether you're playing
casually or pushing yourself
competitively
the game's still in early development
but we're gearing up to let you in as
soon as possible
so register right now to participate in
our early rollout phases
thank you so much for watching we really
want your input
so please reach out to us on social
media
[Music]